I want to review a little
bit of what we
did in the last video.
And maybe draw a larger, more
spread-out diagram.
Because I think in the last
video I started to cram things
on the right-hand side here.
And this is a very important
concept, so I want to do it
nice and spread-out in a way
that we can breathe.
And maybe in the process I can
fill in some more blanks.
So let's go back and draw the
membrane of a thylakoid that's
sitting inside of a chloroplast.
I'm going to draw
this same membrane here.
So let me draw it nice
and spread out.
So let me draw a nice big
membrane like that.
That's the inside
of the membrane.
So you can imagine that this
loops around and that would
form the thylakoid.
On this side of the membrane
we have the lumen.
And on the outside of the
membrane we have the stroma,
where all the fluid that fills
up the choloroplast. So this
is the stroma right there.
And this is just a kind of
standard membrane that we see
in a lot of organelles.
But this is actually a membrane
within an organelle.
And then maybe there will be
a phospho-bilipid layer.
And I just say that, or I'm
pointing that out because I
want to think a little bit
about, in this video, how
protons can actually get
across this thing.
How do we use the energy from
these electrons going to lower
energy states to actually pump
protons across this membrane.
So you know when you have these
bilipid layers, your
outside is hydrophilic.
And of course, it's hydrophilic
because it
operates well in a polar
environment.
And then the insides are
non-polar or they're
hydrophobic and you
have these tales.
So I could draw the whole
membrane like that, but I
won't do that.
It will take me forever.
But let me draw some of the
components that I did in the
last video.
So we have these complexes that
span across this membrane.
And the place we started
off with was the
photosystem II complex.
And then later on we have the
photosystem I complex.
And let me draw the ATP
synthase right here.
So ATP synthase also
spans across it.
Then it has little
motor part of it.
And the hydrogens go through and
it spins the motor and it
crams the phosphate groups
into the ADP to make ATP.
I'll talk about that
in a second.
But the first thing I want to
point out is, as I said in the
last video, the first place
where the electrons get
excited is in the chlorophyll
and photosystem II.
And then it gets less and less
and less excited, it gets
headed off from one complex
to another complex.
And eventually ends up
in photosystem I.
It gets excited again.
Then it gets handed off, handed
off, the whole time
that energy is being used to
transfer hydrogen protons from
the stroma into the lumen .
But the first question that I
would ask is, why is this
called photosystem II, while
this is called photosystem I
when we're starting over here?
And the reason is, this was
discovered first. Even though
in the light reaction it
actually comes into use, or it
comes into play, second.
This was discovered first.
That's why they call it
photosystem I.
But the reality is photosystem
II is where
everything starts from.
Now in some textbooks you'll
also see this written as P680.
And you'll see photosystem
I written as P700.
And these numbers come from the
wavelength of light that
is best absorbed by the
chlorophyll in these
photosystems. So 680 corresponds
to 680 nanometers.
That's the wavelength of light
that this absorbs the best.
700 corresponds to
700 nanometers.
That's the wavelength of
light it absorbs best.
Now what I want to do here is
draw a little diagram below
here to kind of talk
more about the
electron energy states.
I just kind of handwaved it a
little bit in the last video.
So I'm going to draw a
little diagram here.
And over here I'm going to write
the different things
that the electron can
be a part of.
So right now the electrons
can be part of H2O.
It could be part of
chlorophyll A.
It could be a part of-- I'll
talk more about this in a
little bit-- pheophytin And
then you have all of the
molecules or the complexes
it can become a part of.
I'll actually write
them down here.
So let me write.
I don't want to take
up too much space.
Plastoquinone and then there's
a cytochrome B6F complex.
I'll just write B6F.
Then you have plastocyanin .
I'll just write as PC.
You don't have to
memorize these.
You'll forget them in
a week if you do.
But unless you're studying
photosynthesis, then it might
make sense to memorize them.
And this is in photosystem II.
Then you have chlorophyll
in photosystem I.
And then you have some other,
you know you have ferredoxin
I'll just write FD for
ferredoxin Some other
molecules, you keep going and
then you have your eventual
electron acceptor NADP plus.
Which, once it accepts the
electron, becomes NADPH.
Now, electrons are very-- so
this is, if we go up that's a
high energy state, down it's
a low energy state.
So electrons are already
very comfortable.
in water.
And in chlorophyll A they're
even more comfortable.
At least this is
how I view it.
But left to its own devices,
this electron will never leave
chlorophyll A.
But we know what happens.
A photon comes in from 93
million miles away.
You could imagine photons as
little light packets or you
could view it as a light
wave. Either way.
And it excites-- not necessarily
directly the
chlorophyll A.
It might excite other antenna
chlorophyll or
other pigment molecules.
And then through resonance
energy, you can imagine them
vibrating, and it eventually
will excite the
photophorylation A directly.
Or excite the electrons in
chlorophyll A directly.
And this dude right
here gets excited.
Let me do that in a
brighter color.
So it goes to a high
energy state.
So the electron here is in
a high energy state.
Ignore that lumen right there.
It has nothing to do
with this electron.
And then it goes-- and actually
when it goes to the
high energy state, maybe I
should draw it like this, it
actually shows up
in pheophytin.
That is the primary
electron acceptor.
And it's actually a chlorophyll
A molecule.
Actually, let me show you
what a chlorophyll A
molecule looks like.
This is what a chlorophyll
A molecule looks like.
In general, it has a
hydrocarbon tail.
You see that right here.
And it has a porphyrin ring.
Or porphyrin head, I guess
you could call it.
This little group right here
is called a porphyrin.
And right in the center of
it, you have a magnesium.
That green right there, that's
a magnesium ion.
And when the photon comes in or
when the resonance energy
comes in from some of the
antenna molecules, electrons
in the double bond sitting
here in the
porphyrin head get excited.
Those are the electrons that
we're talking about.
And they get excited.
And the first electron acceptor
is this pheophytin
that I just talked about.
Pheophytin.
It actually looks just like a
chlorophyll, but it has no
magnesium ion in the middle.
And maybe I'm getting a little
bit into the weeds a little
bit too much.
But the pheophytin, you actually
see in this diagram
right here.
It's part of this photosystem
complex.
So the electron, you can
imagine, jumping from the
chlorophyll to the pheophytin
that does not have that
magnesium in the center.
And when it sits in the
pheophytin it's at a very,
very, very, very, high
energy state.
And then it keeps being
transferred from the
pheophytin.
It goes to the plastoquinone So
maybe we go to a slightly
lower energy state here.
We keep using the electron
in green.
Then it keeps going to a
slightly lower energy state in
the cytochrome B6F complex.
And then you have the
plastocyanin complex, lower
energy state.
And then eventually it goes into
photosystem I at an even
lower energy state.
Maybe slightly higher than the
energy state that it was
originally in the chlorophyll A
molecule in photosystem II.
Another photon or another set
of photons comes and hits
photosystem I.
Maybe its antenna molecules,
through resonance energy, that
excites the electron.
It might directly hit the
chlorophyll in photosystem in
its reaction center.
And then this gets
excited again.
And so once again we have an
electron with a high potential
that can keep going to, from one
molecule to another as it
gets more and more
comfortable.
And this releases energy that
can drive the proton pump.
And it eventually ends
up in the NADPH.
At a fairly high level
of energy still.
This electron can still be
transferred to other things
and release energy.
And we'll see that when we
talk about the light
independent reactions.
Now the whole point of me
showing you this is, I wanted
to kind of depict graphically
that the electron is starting
off at a pretty low
energy state.
And the only way this happens
is by energy from light.
This would not happen
on its own.
Going from a low energy state
to a higher energy state.
And I touched on in the last
video, you have this electron
going here and it gets
transferred from one molecule
to another.
Gets excited again, then keeps
going all the way, eventually
being accepted by the NAD
plus to become NADPH.
And you're like, where
did that H come from?
You could say, well that
H is a proton.
It gets that electron and then
they merge together and you
have NADPH.
But either way.
But the question is, what
replaces this electron?
And that's where that amazing
thing that I talked about in
the last video happens.
Water gets oxidized.
Oxidizing is losing electrons.
OIL RIG.
So water gets oxidized by
the water oxidation
on photosystem II.
And that electron ends up and
replaces the electron in the
chlorophyll.
So once again, that's an amazing
idea, that you're
oxidizing oxygen.
So the net effect of what
happens is, is you're using
energy, using this photon
energy right here, to
essentially strip electrons
off of water.
And as you know, when it's on
water it's spending most of
its time on the oxygen.
So it essentially strips
electrons off of oxygen and
put them in a higher energy
state and have
them end up on NADPH.
And in the process, it
had gone to an even
higher energy state.
And then as it goes down to
NADPH, you are pumping protons
across the membrane.
We learned in the last video,
through chemiosmosis,
eventually goes through the ATP
synthase channel, turns
around this part of this protein
complex or enzyme
complex and actually
generates ATP.
ATP from ADP and phosphate
groups.
And in the electron transport
chain video, when I talk about
cellular respiration, I give a
visual concept of how this
actually might happen.
How you could, as these go
through, you actually can jam
together the ATP and the ADP.
So that's another question in
my head is, we talk about
these electrons going from
one molecule to another.
But how does that actually
pump hydrogen through?
And I'm just going to do a very
gross oversimplification.
I'm sure it's much more
complicated in
actual plant cells.
But you could imagine that we
have our pheophytin right here
that has that electron
on it right there.
Maybe it has its electron
right there.
This is a gross
oversimplification.
And then you have your
plastoquinone right here.
That's the next acceptor.
Now maybe on this protein
complex right there, the point
that wants to accept the
electron is right there.
And let's say that there's
another point on it that can
accept a hydrogen.
Maybe it accepts a hydrogen
proton there.
So you can imagine when it's on
this side of the membrane,
a hydrogen can become attached
right there.
And this guy will want to
be attracted to that.
So he'll rotate around.
So you can imagine this-- if
this is kind of a wheel-- this
attraction.
Because the electron wants to
go into a lower energy state
right here.
It'll rotate around.
That'll allow, essentially, this
hydrogen as it rotates.
As this molecule, as this
protein rotates around this
hydrogen will be able to
cross the barrier.
And then once this guy and
that guy meet, then the
hydrogen will be on
the other side.
And so it can freely
go away again.
So that's, at least in my
head, how I imagine the
electrons going from a high
energy state to a lower energy
state, how that can actually
drive a reaction.
Remember, the electrons
want to do this.
So they'll attract the different
parts of the
molecules together.
And as those molecules turn and
rotate and move, that can
help facilitate hydrogen going
from the stroma, the outside
of the thylakoid, to the inside
of the thylakoid.
That will drive the chemiosmosis
later on.
Now there's one other point
I want to touch on here.
Everything I've described so
far, we started with an
electron in water.
And obviously when water loses
its hydrogens, it loses both
the hydrogen protons and
electrons associated with it.
You end up with just water.
So you start off with hydrogens
and then you end up
with just O2.
And then the hydrogen protons--
the electron got
taken up by the chlorophyll.
When you start off with that,
we've seen already that you
end up with the electron
sitting in NADPH.
The electron sitting
out here in NADPH.
At some point you have NAD
as the final acceptor.
Let me do it in the
right color.
You have NAD plus as
the final acceptor.
And it becomes NADPH.
You can imagine it accepts
maybe a hydrogen
proton from out here.
It accepts the electron from
this electron transport chain
in photosynthesis.
And it becomes NADPH and that
travels in the stroma, which
is where the dark reactions
occur that actually produce
the carbohydrate.
But this idea of an electron
going from water to NADPH,
this is called non-cyclic
photophosphorylation And it's
called non-cyclic because you're
not reusing the same
electrons over and over again.
The electrons start off, and
depending how you view it, in
the chlorophyll or the water.
And they end up in the NADPH.
Now there's another type of
photophosphorylation and you
might guess what it's called.
It's called cyclic.
Cyclic photophosphorylation
We'll see when we study the
dark cycles or the Calvin cycle
or the dark reactions or
the light independent
reactions, that it
uses a lot of ATP.
Actually ATP in disproportion
to the
amount of NADPH it uses.
It uses both, but it
uses a ton of ATP.
So cyclic phosphorylation only
produces ATP and actually does
not oxidize water.
So what happens in that
situation is this electron,
after it gets activated or
after it gets excited in
photosystem I, it's the
electron, it eventually ends
up-- instead of at NADPH, it
ends up at photosystem II.
So instead of this guy having
to be replaced by electrons
from water, this guy, in cyclic
photophosphorylation
ends up-- well, maybe I should
do it from here-- ends up
getting replaced by the
original electrons.
It gets excited here.
It goes from molecule to
molecule, lower energy states,
hydrogen gets pumped
into the lumen.
Gets excited again in
photosystem I and it enters
lower and lower energy states.
But then ends up again
in photosystem II.
That is cyclic
photophosphorylation.
So you can imagine in this
situation, since the electron
never ends up at NAD plus, you
don't end up producing NADPH.
And since you're replacing
this electron from the
photosynthesis or from the
electron transport chain
directly, you don't
have to strip the
electrons off of the water.
So you're not going to
produce your oxygen.
So, in this situation--
so this non-cyclic
phosphorylation, which
is kind of what most
photophosphorylation, is what
most people associate with
photophosphorylation, this
produces O2 and NADPH.
And of course it produces ATP.
While cyclic
photophosphorylation, because
it doesn't have to strip
electrons off of water and the
electrons don't end up at NADPH,
only produces ATP.
So I think we now have a very
good understanding, hopefully,
of the light reactions
in photosynthesis.
We're now ready to take
the products of this.
Now let's remember what
the products were.
Well, the oxygen just
gets eliminated.
We don't need the
oxygen anymore.
But that goes into the
atmosphere and you and I can
breathe that and we can use that
for cellular respiration.
But in the photosynthesis
context, we've now generated a
bunch of ATP.
And now we have a
bunch of NADPH.
And we can use that in
conjunction with carbon
dioxide to produce actual
carbohydrates in the stroma.
Outside the thylakoids, but
we're still inside of the
chloroplast. And I'll cover
that in the next video.